da genau ob ich bin ja blick heute mit
dem logischen hallo schüssel mit dabei
ist die sache eigentlich gleich am
ersten runde einen kanal noch in der
regel schaue ich nicht in der runde war
ich dann einfach nur gas geben so damm
planmäßig sollte man eigentlich eine
runde anziehen wenn ich dann im
einstelligen moment habt wenn ich jetzt
über den negativen effekt hat mit dem
mich da nicht ein jump nicht machen will
dann mache ich das dann gute taktik
warum über seo geil da ist einfach kein
blog plattform schafft man ihn jetzt
nicht als super alter was ist das wie
unfair das ist der ist einfach so eine
ändert es hätte da sein müssen
und die war beim ersten mal nicht da war
nur die andere partikel aus der runde
gleich am anfang so wie so oder so mal
anschneiden dass wir bald wieder eine
location eine lobby eine lüge dass wir
bald wieder eine lose kooperation
zusammen haben gibt das war nicht nur da
wir haben einmal das und dann noch das
und das andere
also alles 3
bei dem ein name sogar ein dreier am
start oh mein gott
mit mit zu allem der auch in seinen
aufgaben nur über drei er redet ihr
könnt mal ihr könnt ma lin in die
kommentare schreiben
welche youtuber mit dem ich kontakt habe
könnte es sein der in seinen aufnahmen
kann man über 3er und solche sachen
werden
ich würde mich würde mal vermuten da
gibt es einen auf den das besonders
zutrifft da gibt es einen der ist auch
der wagen ja nein denn ich nicht zu
viele tipps geben machtverzicht gibt
gibt keinen tipp das richtig machen
würde man live bilder jetzt darunter
hätte jetzt nicht runter doch schon habe
ich jetzt hier die kiste verpasst
garantiert aber mir egal wir machen
weiter bis auf platz zwei hinter mir und
stunden ja ich musste wussten ich bin
krank ich bin total krank ich gehe immer
total ab in den runden über das kranke
gameplay hier richtig übel sagt schon
wie sie das war knapp
ja weil ich kriege so ruhige kisten hier
was wir mit einem gold und zwei sticks
selbst sei nicht zwei gold noch grafite
hätte wird mir das nur zu einem
goldstreifen das ist scheiße
er kennt sich mit crafting aus war du
bringst dafür noch mal den hut der
letzten aufnahme schon gebracht er ist
immer noch schlecht
er wird irgendwann gut der xbox auch
scheiße was ich jetzt sagen also auch
eingeführt die bahn am anfang lustig zum
beispiel der neckar spruch dass das ist
doch witzig muss man sagen ja aber der
war auch am anfang mal cool derweil
eigentlich nervig aber dementiert am
anfang nervig sind werden nur ganz
selten wie die coolen
im laufe der geschichte schon wieder
choral was zur hölle choral ist das neue
cool und herbert grönemeyer ist der
neuer ist neues lcd sie in welchem film
bist du das gerade nicht die kette
herbert grönemeyer
doch aber ist das eine hat sich anderswo
spongebob kommt coca cola habe ich nie
gescheut mal mein leben mein gott
belehrt die man bitte in den kommentaren
das hat mein leben geprägt so behindert
und spongebob wäre ich nicht wo ich
jetzt bin ja das übelste emotionale
fragt ja genau
dank des transports danke dass du meine
kindheit zerstört
hier kann ich nachts nicht mehr schlafen
ich liebe dich die schlafstörung
trainings von check gegen herbert
grönemeyer wird jetzt in letzter zeit
sieht man auch über die poster von dem
astana ja ich habe mir auch das neue
album geholt stichwort poster leute da
könnt ihr mir was sagen ihr seht im
hintergrund hier diese ecke da dann wir
zum kleines post senkt aber wie der name
schon sagt das ist klein
wir bräuchten was größeres ich finde
aber im internet keine seite bei der man
irgendwie poster im format also im mega
format bestellen kann also wir bräuchten
schon einst so gibt diese einer aus der
echten fernsehwerbung 2 x 32 x 3 meter
bräuchten wir wahrscheinlich schon
sitzen darauf machen die ich mach's
kulig ich bin i can't nicht selbst ein
foto motiv drauf packen sondern einfach
irgendwie so ein foto von fotografie
druck von fotodrucker ich ganz gerne
es geht ja du weißt der tobi diese
aufnahme läuft und die letzte kiste
richtig lanciert telematik oder gar
nicht
eigentlich wieder so oft wie extreme ja
so wie früher
das hat sich noch nicht wieder
normalisiert aber eventuell auch heute
morgen streamen oder haltet euch mal
bereit gut dass das anspricht ich muss
gleich nochmal zum baumarkt und für
meine mutter was erledigen aber danach
könnte man doch eigentlich mal machen
nein ich habe es nicht als ob ich jetzt
diese kurz zum schluss verpacke das ist
auch so easy peasy luisi leute ich
wachse jetzt echt noch so kurz zum
schluss das kann nicht sein
gerade als ob davor ganz ehrlich wie
kann man so eine geistige blockade haben
einfach niemand so wie er einfach die
ganze zu abgehackt sprechen ballack voll
voll es überall 10 gerutscht
ich hab mich voll und leben wieder
stress gesetzt
bldg
moment mal so da hätten wir zwei so gar
nicht
del team
kirkel katja kompass mich ein mitnehmen
ich will noch ein thema im boden war so
ich schwebte er denn der junge ja ich
habe auch noch genommen division geholt
sehr gut genau das genau so sollte das
passieren sehr gut sehr gut sehr gut
jetzt bleibt oder weg von mir kräftig an
graffiti an junge leser ab ich brauche
gerade ab ich versuche den chain wasser
hier oben so gut kirschen recherchen
noch dann ist wie wir alle so viel
einstecken
wie viele eingestellt wie kann man so
viel fressen warum halten hat man leute
die big planet essen das macht keinen
sinn alter.de gelände witzen so schlecht
geworden das ist echt grausam was was
macht der typ hier also ich gleich ein
ich versteh ich denke fest warte ich
verstehe ihn nicht da hat ebenso viel
gefressen
der kann nicht die ganzen kids
eingesteckt haben der hat nur eine
rüstung auf dem eis ist die situation
ein bisschen kalt ich habe mich ja auch
du bastard jetzt reicht's jetzt wird
rasiert
also was liegt da aber du kommst du
nicht raus mit benzin von außen kommt
dann herein
ok alle noch 22 neben all diese andere
typ den man nicht trotzdem nicht das bin
ich nicht
also bis zum wachstum bei minimalem
boden muss ich sein aber etwas im block
im block im boden läuft ja com gestern
erholt sich einfach hat mich geht abdi
hat er mich der mich geheimnis macht
will ich auch mal warten
wie viel der einsteigt ist unfassbar und
optimieren
das gibt's doch nicht alle timo ja genau
die team deswegen habe ich darauf habe
ich mich angegriffen
total aufregend am sorry nicht erst den
armen schwachen ja wir müssen jetzt
natürlich erst mal den team vorwurf
widerlegen damit wieder definitiv hübsch
seiten kein problem haben
jetzt könnt ihr hier noch ein weiter weg
über das eisglätte war wunderbar ja das
war es von heute würde ich sagen bloß
eine beschreibung hinterlassen daumen
nach oben da wir sind zunächst wieder
träumen